6-Mute English from BBCLearningEnglish.com
Hello, this is 6-minute English from BBC Learning English. I'm Neil.
And I'm Beth.
As the world switches from fossil fuels to renewable sources of energy,
solar panels are appearing in more and more places and with good reason.
Yes, today the world is generating 10 times more solar electricity than a decade ago.
And what's more, solar is the only energy source on track to meet the UN's 2050 net zero targets.
But there's a problem. Space.
As the rooftops in our cities and towns get filled up with solar panels,
finding space for them becomes difficult.
In this programme we'll be exploring two surprising solar projects to build PV panels
in all kinds of weird and wonderful places.
And as usual, we'll be learning some useful new vocabulary too.
Great, but first I have a question for you, Beth.
Harnessing the power of the Sun is not new. In fact, solar power dates back over 2,700 years.
In 213 BC, mirrors were used to reflect sunlight back onto Roman ships attacking the city of Syracuse,
causing them to catch fire.
But which ancient Greek philosopher was responsible for this solar heat ray?
Was it A, our comedies, B, Socrates or C, Pythagoras?
I think it was Pythagoras.
Okay, Beth, I'll reveal the answer later in the programme.
Our first surprising solar project takes place in one of the world's biggest car parks owned by a US supermarket giant Walmart.
Joshua P.S., a researcher at Western University in Ontario Canada,
wants Walmart to introduce solar canopies in all their car parks.
A canopy is a cover fixed over something to provide shelter or decoration.
Joshua's canopies protect customers' cars from the sun and rain while the solar panels
fixed on top generate electricity.
This electricity can be used by the supermarket,
or given to customers to charge their electric car for free.
Here's Myra and Noobie, presenter of BBC World Service programme People Fixing the World,
discussing Joshua's idea.
Of course, if Walmart or an equivalent retailer were to do this,
they wouldn't just be paying off their investment in green electricity.
They would be adding hundreds of thousands of electric charging points across the US,
which would make switching to electric vehicles more enticing for American drivers.
So we're starting to see more and more of these occur.
I think in the very near future we're going to see a enormous increase.
Solar canopies provide free charging points, making electric cars a cheaper,
more enticing option for American drivers.
If something is enticing, it's attractive because it offers advantages or pleasures.
Joshua hopes we'll see more solar canopies in the near future, at some time very soon.
Our second surprising solar project is quite literally out of this world.
Martin Soltao is founder of Space Solar, a company planning to build solar panels 22,000 miles away
in outer space. With no night or changing seasons,
it's believed that solar panels in space would generate 13 times as much electricity as on Earth.
Martin's plans sound like science fiction and haven't been tried out yet.
But the idea of solar power from space has existed since the 1960s,
as Martin explained to BBC World Service programme People Fixing the World.
And then in really the late 60s, the American scientist Peter Clasier,
designed the first technical, technically practical system.
And after that NASA studied it on and off right through the decades.
And so it's really only in the last six or seven years that it's actually now become
economically feasible. And so the whole cost of getting things into space has tumbled by over 90%.
NASA has studied the idea of putting solar panels in space on and off,
meaning occasionally or from time to time since the 1960s.
Recently, the costs of travelling to space have tumbled, decreased quickly and in a short time,
making Martin's idea for space solar panels economically feasible.
If a business plan is economically feasible, the economic advantages achieved are greater
than the economic costs. It seems that a good idea is a good idea, whether it's thousands of years
ago or in the near future. With that, it's time to reveal the answer to my question.
Yes, you asked me which famous ancient Greek philosopher used the power of the sun to
destroy enemy room and ships in 213 BC. I said it was Pythagoras.
Which was, I'm afraid to say, the wrong answer, Beth. It was actually Archimedes who used
parabolic mirrors to burn the enemy's wooden ships at Syracuse, a trick which school children
still do today using a magnifying glass and sun beams to make fire.
Right, let's recap the vocabulary we've learned from this program, starting with
canopy, a cover that's fixed over an object to shelter or decorate it.
The adjective enticing means attractive because of the advantages or benefits it offers.
In the near future, it means very soon. The phrase on and off means occasionally or from time to time.
If the cost or price of something has tumbled, it's decreased quickly in a short time.
And finally, if a business plan is economically feasible, the economic advantages achieved
will be greater than the economic costs. Once again, our six minutes are up. Goodbye for now.
Bye.